1963 et il reste encore quelques
kilomètres j'ai hâte j'ai hâte derniers
kilomètres au compteur pour fabrice
bonnet sa 307 break acheté d'occasion en
2007 quinze ans plus tard une
quarantaine de révision et aux contrôles
techniques le picard achève son périple
à sochaux est franchi symboliquement la
barre du million dans l'enceinte de
visite du doubs
[Applaudissements]
où ils ont fait la voiture à nous on a
fait des kilomètres ja jeremic a fait
l'entretien eux voilà c'est ensemble
qu'on y est arrivé à quelque chose
prononcera jamais rives
avec sa tournée de remerciement fabrice
gommer a voulu saluer ce travail
d'équipé des ouvriers de la ligne de
montage de sochaux n'était pas peu fier
et j'ai participé à la fabrication
puisque j'ai commencé ici on fait rage
il ya quinze ans en arrière et je
travaillais sur les côtés de caisse donc
j'étais dans les ateliers donc je pense
que il ya un fait demeure aussi dans le
million ça nous apporte de la fierté de
un coup de coude de satisfaction et sa
chance le coeur de voir les clients de
dire à nos portes nous remercier et
féliciter pour la petite histoire le
compteur de la 307 n'étant pas prévus
pour afficher sept chiffres il est donc
resté bloqué à 999
1999 km le propriétaire envisage lui de
léguer sa fidèle compagne au laboratoire
peugeot pour percer le secret de cette
étonnante longévité
j'avais presque oublié qu'on avait pas
de place à 2 l'an